hello everyone I hope you're having an
excellent Sunday because we have a very
nice game between 11:00 Oregon and
Fabiano Caruana
from the st. Louis rapid and blitz event
it's a five-day event that has a prize
fund of some hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to wear first prize is a thirty
seven thousand and I believe five
hundred dollars and yesterday was the
first day of the rapid section so there
will be a single round-robin with the
three days of rapid and then after that
a double round-robin with 18 rounds of
blitz which will be of course very
enjoyable and crazy and run one was very
eventful and enough round one day one
was very very eventful and produced some
wonderful games but before we check that
out we do have a nice photo challenge
it's also a part of the of this st.
Louis event so who are the two gentlemen
in the photo I will give you a little
hint
they are the official commentators for
the Russian stream and also the the
Grandmaster on the right is a substitute
for Alexander Grisha
if he will not be able to play this
tournament so that being said let's
check it out Irina has the white pieces
and he opens this game with E for so
like I said it's a rapid event 25
minutes per player and 10 seconds delay
starting with a move one we have c6
Fabiano goes for the caro-kann defense
d4 and d5 so it's hard to say is he now
preparing the caro-kann defense
or is he just not playing the petrov
Shawcross and doesn't see what what
crazy lines he has in store for him for
November he captures on d5 seek after
Sun d5 and Bishop to d3 so the exchange
variation Knight to c6 c3 defending the
d4 pawn we have a knight to f6 Bishop to
f4 and now Bishop to g4 by Caruana Queen
to b3 now attacking the b7 pawn we have
Queen 37 defending the pawn and now
comes Knight d2 e 6 we have Knight G to
f3 Bishop to d6 offering to trade
bishops mercial captures Queen captures
and here of course white could go
this juicy b7 pawn or he could simply
castle if it was a if it was a classical
game probably Iranian with Castle here
but Iranian is not want to back down
from a fight so he plays Queen after Sun
b7 and says that this is perfectly fine
we have rook to b8 attacking the Queen
Queen to a6 and now not capturing the
rook here not capturing the pawn
immediately because this would you know
bring a lot of problems for white I'm
sure all of you can see it Bishop to b5
there is no way to prevent the attack on
this night so here you would have to
give up the exchange I have to recapture
screen captures you would simply be down
the exchange so after rook to b8 Queen
to a 6 we have castles by Caruana
Bishop to b5 a move that was not all
that necessary here probably he thought
maybe Corona will play something like
rook to c8 but in fact he simply plays
rook to be six kicks away the Queen and
the defense of the knight on c6 so
perhaps a slight loss of a temple for
our own young Queen to f4 and now simply
nice to e7 getting the knight out of the
way Knights t5 attacking the bishop on
g4 and here Knight to g6 we have Knight
captures Knight captures and here oh
well it's not a critical moment in the
game but it could have been a critical
moment in the game because here h3 was
played g3 seems to be a better move
because after h3 Caruana played Knight
back to f6 but he also could have played
this wonderful sacrificed Knight
captures on f2 all right it's not all
that you know scientific as it does you
know you have to really feel creative
and you know I want to be willing to
create something to go for something
like this if you as it's it's not
impossible to calculate everything here
after King captures rook after b8 this
is the idea threatening a six grab the
b2 pawn and after white plays something
like Bishop to d3 as a a six will be
played rook captor sambito is coming and
now Bishop to see to the Queen will now
be guarding the bishop
here we have Queen to f4 check attacking
the king and the night here on D - we
have Knight to f3 blocking and now Queen
to e4 with a double attack on the bishop
here and now it's a question of whether
white would defend properly or or or not
any defense of the bishop with the rock
isn't all that great Knights to a one is
the best move but you know who could
possibly find all the all these nice
moves but okay after h3 Khurana did not
go for this wonderful sacrifice he
played Knight to f6 we have nice to be
three and now comes a five if I have a
very nice move because now if you
capture here and captures white is gonna
lose castle in privileges he will have
to play something like into f1 and then
black will be on the attack here after a
five iron and finally castles but this
allows Khurana to create this well not a
passed pawn but a very fast pawn so rook
F to e 1 we have night to h5 now
threatening to bring the knight over to
H over to f4
Bishop to f1 bringing the bishop back to
the defense
Knight to h4 now and here comes Queen to
a5 Queen to a5 is the move that loses
the game 4-4 Arnon but it's not all that
easy to see why here all a one of the
ideas that was not play the game adhere
Khurana played Queen to g6 which is a
very nice move but he also could have
played a Queen to f4 after Queen to f4
then there's really not all that much to
do here whatever you do for example if
you play something like nice to d2
getting the knight out of the B file the
Queen will simply capture it and if you
play any move for example something like
Bishop to Bishop to e2 this of course
does not work because now the rook is
coming to g6 and there there will be no
defense whatever white place black will
simply sacrifice half of the pieces and
that will be it but Khurana had a
similar idea instead of Queen two after
Queen to a5 instead of Queen to f4 he
played Queen
g6 which is a bit slower as now the rook
cannot come immediately at the g6 but it
works quite well because Aragon played
Queen to a5 instead of Queen captures on
a seven but again it's very hard to
understand why this doesn't work for
example Queen captures on a seven
instead of Queen to a5 there would have
been better because now rook to e3 will
not be a nice a good enough defense now
you can play Knight to f3 check of
course you cannot capture and after King
to h1 and now you play Queen to g5 which
is the idea basically making the room
for the rook here and now rook captures
on f3 white black and simply capture on
f3 for example see for whatever why
place captures captures and now Knight
to f4 rogue blocks and rook comes to g6
this is the whole point of this
variation so this is what I wanted to
say here that after 9th to h4 instead of
this Queen to a5 move Queen to captures
an a7 would have been better for R&M
because now rook to e3 after this Queen
to g6 now rook to e3 would have been
playable because now this nice to f3
Czech runs into King - each one as we've
seen in the previous variation but now
Queen to g5 runs into rook captures on
f3 and now you no longer have the option
of capturing because the rook on d6 is
undefended so here you would have to
play an in-between move rook captures
and after a captures he captures on f3
and here Queen to be 700 would be well
for white so getting back to our
position after Knight to h4 so Queen to
f4
after this Queen to a5 move Queen to f4
would have been the best idea because it
immediately allows the rook to g6 like
we've said Caruana went for Queen to g6
and then now we have Queen captures on
b5 like we've said rook to e3 does not
work in this position because the rook
on d6 is defended and now karana goes
for Knight to f3
this comes with check of course you
cannot capture the knight King to h1 and
here what do you play in this
position immediately when I saw this
position I thought oh yes here comes the
American beauty queen queen g3 but of
course I thought yes now F captures
Knight captures and it's checkmate what
a wonderful checkmate
but unfortunately for Caruana the queen
doesn't have to be captured first white
can play G captures on f3 and then after
a forced variation that is Queen
captures with Czech Bishop to g2
blocking and now Queen captures Bishop
King captures Knight f4 check for King
the king and queen king knows Knight
captures but now after rook captures on
e4 white would simply be up to pawns so
this does not work so here there is a
much better move Cora wanna play so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best move for black here to
move Caruana played so I will give it a
couple of seconds if you want to decide
whether to do it or not it's a nice
Sunday puzzle of course you can always
capture the rook but that's not the best
move if that was the best move I would
not you know create a puzzle out of it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations for not going for the
American beauty and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
Knight the g3 check now there are no
options white has to capture tonight we
have a pawn captures and Queen captures
and this is move 25 there is no defense
against Queen to H - checkmate
an interesting align is of course G
captures an f3 but then look to g6 wins
the threat is Queen to g1 checkmate if
you move the bishop then of course Queen
captures Bishop is checkmate and if you
move the bishop anywhere else so the
rook can guarded the G file then of
course you can either checkmate on g2 or
even Queen captures on h3 also will be
checkmate so you can simply resign here
but it's you know it's never a wise to
resign and move 25 because then you know
everywhere on the internet it will say
you lost in 25 moves
so first Ireland decided to give up the
Queen Queen e5 who have Knight captures
on e5 pawn captures on e5 and now Queen
captures on e5 so giving up the Queen 4
for a piece
we have looked to d1 and now f5 so this
is now completely lost position for
white but you know they decided to play
it out rook to d6 offering a trade of
rooks rook captures an a7 Queen to g3 we
have rook to b1 and the now f4 simply
pushing those those pawns Knights the c5
we have Queen to b3 b4 now f3 we have
rook to e7 f captures and G to Bishop
captures and g2 and here after rook to
h6 finally 11 Aran and resigned the game
as there's really nothing to do here
you're getting checkmated rook capture
screen captures the rook is controlling
the F file now it is indeed all over but
now it's move 35 and it's always better
to resign I'll move 35 then I move 25
and you know it's a rapid game there's
always a chance your opponent will mess
up so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I did prepare the standings
after day 1 so here they are
Fabiano Caruana with a perfect score he
won't all of all three of his games and
during the rapid section you will get
two points for a victory unlike in the
blade section where you will get only
one point for a victory so here as you
can see six points about the deaths for
three games he won all of them maxime
Bashir in second with Fork
tied with Sergei kurakin with four then
mama D are of almond and Nakamura with
311 Aragon a linear Dominguez and
Alexander we shook with two and Wesley
so in last place with one point so it's
interesting
Wester always has a crazy crazy days in
this grand chester this is the third
part of the Grantchester so perhaps he
will have better luck in day 2 and 3 and
also perhaps in the blood section so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Jamie
comas Daniel drayage and Sean Wilcox and
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon perhaps with another
interesting game from the st. Louis
rapid event or if I make up my mind I
will see if I will remake the game three
of the facial versus the amount of
series I think all and I'll see you soon